to either test out the horizontal Mambo
or tell her you don't want to ruin the
Friendship those are the only two things
if you're going to test out the
horizontal Mambo though say let's just
test out let's give it a try let's give
it a whirl sweetie dude sweetie I'll
come here come on sit down there swoot
it all Let's test it out there we go oh
my God there we go that's nice and like
sweetie dog here we go and turn around
and oh and there we go and up oh and
there we go yeah that's not gonna work
out
rank
hello hello hello
[Music]
and
action okay
what's up what's up dude you know like
you know uh welcome to Lifeline this is
the world's greatest podcast and you can
scientifically prove that so do not
argue and say you agree in the comments
and they do agree and then say you agree
and then I'll respond and I'll say I
agree with you agreeing with me you know
what
um I added a Sunday Show in Las Vegas
I'm going to be in Vegas soon
um I'm gonna do it's not necessarily
that don't push me toward I'm gonna be
out there I'm going to be doing all
sorts of different stuff I'm not going
to do my normal tour I'm gonna do new
stuff and different stuff and some of
the tour but yeah is that interesting
yeah but it's not really about anything
to do with what I said but it's cool but
when you say new stuff you mean like
Carrot Top you're gonna have a treasure
chest up on Vegas I'm gonna do that yeah
you mean just for the Vegas show we're
gonna you're gonna not do well it's at a
club so it's not at a big theater so I'm
gonna I'm doing it to come up with oh uh
at least I'm not gonna do all new stuff
I'm still gonna do some of it don't push
me stuff but I want to give myself a
small a smaller audience so I can
do test stuff out if I want to right so
anyway I'll be there go to chrislea.com
but I'll also be in Charlotte Knoxville
um and a bunch of different other places
uh Nashville Montreal go check it out
Little Rock Arkansas I always forget
about that one for good reason but I'm
gonna be in the world Arkansas for the
first time
um got a question go to watch
lifeline.com dude and I forgot the
hoodie I was gonna wear the hoodie today
the lifeline merch you mess up my
merch.com it's very cool
um uh one-on-one with me matelia.com
book it book it baby and also uh the
patreon patreon.com lifeline luxury it's
absolutely killing and we love it and
it's a good time and it's Mia and Matt
bantern and uh we come out with a bunch
of episodes a month and it's cool man
it's worth it shaking it up huh yep
what's that about this is Magic mind oh
I love Magic Mike no not magic that's
the movie nope this is the movie Magic
oh wow it's so much smaller and real
physical material than I thought
um okay go ahead Channing Tatum is so
good enough uh the uh this is really
good I drink it with my coffee and I'm
sharper for it so there we go you want
to know story oh my and that's the cool
thing about those little bottles is that
you can hear look
it's so bad bad promo look a good promo
though well let me do good promo bad
promo but good promo look I go like this
I'm doing my magic mine
it's a [__]
no I don't like that part but that's the
cool thing about those bottles you could
do that anywhere you could do this
anywhere too
yeah I guess so
um but anyway uh so that's what's going
on dude remember when you did this fake
slate I do okay I was in in college I
was in a short film with this like I was
I guess it was I was the co-lead with
this one guy up a dream and the guy was
like super religious and he like made it
known okay which means that if you're in
a group of people and that person's
there no one's allowed to have fun yeah
I mean because everyone's like he made
it known I don't want to like yeah that
just sucks it's totally sucks the guy
sucked hey so I don't like him and
because it was a college thing in the
short film everybody was like sleeping
in one house six people in a room or
whatever
and that guy was in the room I was
sleeping in and he was even annoying
like when we would go to sleep what do
you mean like how just like policing
everyone's language and stuff oh God
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so it was yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we were
shooting in Maryland and it was
everything about this is awful dead of
winter everything about this is awful
it's terrible dude we stayed there for
the director was babadook uh we stayed
there for a whole weekend and because I
was in it so much because I was I'm a
star really and the director knew me
knew do that and cast me because I'm a
star and um
and Cincy
we were both acting in this one scene me
and the religious guy at like two or
three a.m it was everything about this
office it was like two degrees we had a
wardrobe on that wasn't like for winter
I had like cowboy boots and like a vest
oh my God yeah okay so and it was all
wet water was seated
anyway so we're in there and everybody's
getting frustrated that religious guy's
getting frustrated because he's always
at least he's returned to God you know
and we're like rushing to do a take and
nobody's a pro because it's college and
the Slate the girl doing slave uh who I
don't remember who it was
um
was like hurrying and did it and and I
wasn't really paying attention it was a
close-up on him so it was like in front
of him and I'm just like getting my [__]
ready and then all of a sudden I just
hear okay slate
and then and then ah and I look over
dude he had got his nose clamped come on
in the Slate yeah because it was like
and it just got it pinched them right
here and he was like ah and he was
saying all like non-curse words that are
replaced yeah yeah yeah yeah
by sure what the flip you know
oh my gosh dude that's hilarious that
was honestly I think about all the time
yeah yeah I would too now now that's how
you know that God was on your side yeah
well or yeah right yeah exactly yeah
wrong God Muhammad's up there just like
yeah you know or God's just like can you
stop dude just stop talking stop trying
to get everybody on board and then God
just goes like this and nudges the
little right oh sorry blew a wind and
she's
yeah that's hilarious was it all red oh
dude it was already red so it turned
like right almost they needed to do more
makeup hold wow dude yeah
oh my gosh yeah
I don't even I don't even know if she
knew like she was hurrying around so
much and the clap it did make the sound
so I don't think she was even like
I mean it was such a surprise you know
but yeah that's awesome it was a great
surprise I always wonder if that happens
like that I wonder what the who that
because it's definitely happened before
oh yeah I wonder who the biggest stars
ever happened to it's just like Tom
Cruise you know oh my God the flip and
he flips out who I get the most mad
Russell Crow
dude Russell Crowe would get quiet mad
make sure the person's fired and then
also do other stuff after that to the
person like like psychologically oh oh
yeah not physically no no no no no he
would do physical stuff like throwing
stuff but not at the person but like he
would he would go like they would go
and you go
[Laughter]
and then and then later on after the
day's over he's like I don't think that
she's right for the job like she's good
she's Australian now I don't think she's
careless yeah and then uh she would get
fired and then we'd go home and it would
be like at home and he would just like
be online and like he'd be like
online dude those circles never been
online in his life
dude I heard that Russell Crowe is so
mad so mad at
um
uh people asking him about Gladiator too
you know how they're doing another
Gladiator movie oh yeah and obviously
he's not in it because he's dead it's
his character Andy's fat right well no
but he could be the teacher or something
okay but I heard that he's like I I
should be getting paid he one of his
coaches I should be getting paid with
how much people are asking me about
[__] Gladiator too I'm sure he thinks
he should be getting paid because he
made it so iconic it wouldn't be worth
anything to remake in the first place if
he wasn't in it sure was in it uh you
know oh no come on Pedro Pascal's in it
oh of course I mean of course the most
of course Denzel Washington what I heard
Denzel yep is he the guy that it's about
I don't know because if it's a Denzel
movie you know I'm first in line I don't
think it's a Denzel movie oh I mean why
would he says I was getting to the age
where it's just like although he's
they're doing equalizer with three now
dude right there's so many yeah so
there's so many equalizer movies
and now this I gotta see it now I was
never gonna see this but now Denzel
isn't it well they have they've got big
actors in it which I thought if they
were gonna make a gladiator two or
whatever the hell it's going to be
called
um
I would I would have thought that it
would have been the lower tier one no
but if Ridley's directing it's like a
Prestige sequel It's not right but
really Scott's done some awful [__] but
people don't think that people in
Hollywood still think Really Scott is
like one of the greatest really
legendary filmmakers he's directing
right yeah yeah
uh what has he done lately go to he
recently did the the
movies about the fashion people Gucci
House of Gucci oh is that good that's
not bad
literally hasn't been good since like
the late 70s
that's going crazy oh this is that's
producing yeah Anthony messed it up by
not doing just what he directed well
yeah and Anthony messes up a lot of
stuff Anthony messed up um he was taking
too long to respond to us on text today
so that there's that too he also said
that uh I said it uh how he said dead
reckoning is gonna be a big hit and I
said yeah because it's an established
franchise and Tom Cruise is in it and he
said I said and I said that always make
means that somebody's going to do well
and he said the flash was an established
franchise in a bombed and it wasn't and
it wasn't an establishment at all but he
was saying that it's a DC thing that
they tried to establish in the Justice
League right which is not at all the
same thing it's not but I understand
what he was trying to say but I do too
but it's just because you understand he
was just crying but Michael Keaton's
Batman was in you know a different
argument yeah no that wouldn't that
wouldn't count but yeah but Michael
Keaton's Batman in it but uh so yeah you
got you you were wrong so anyway so it's
all good that you were wrong did you
read did you see the marsh explain alien
Covenant then was that that bombed as an
established franchise
that had already fallen off though true
just because something's a sequel
doesn't mean it's gonna be a hit no
that's not the only reason that had Tom
Cruise in it it would be a it would have
been a massive hit yeah it wouldn't
matter I mean remember when Tom Cruise
actually hit a speed bump in his career
no and he was in The Mummy oh yeah
remember that everyone was like is Tom
Cruise over and he was just like
I'll do Mission Impossible no you know
yeah and then he made Mission Impossible
his speaking of which he wasn't Russell
Crowe in that The Mummy yeah he was
going to be uh Van Helsing or something
they were trying to set up the whole
universe you know oh really yeah so it
was so bad I don't even remember Russell
Crowe uh he was like Dr Frankenstein or
something oh wow wow uh anyway uh yeah
so that's what's up I want wrestler to
get into back into real acting again
like when he wasn't just like a movie
star that showed up but there was
Gladiator there was The Insider yeah The
Insider is like he looks like but that's
it though really no no no no no he was
uh what else was he good in uh well I
mean there's this stuff that LA
Confidential the stuff that got him over
yeah oh right right right right right
right in Australia yeah but L.A
confidential was big huge I mean that's
what kind of made him a star right right
what's the Master and Commander Master
and Commander was a really big one that
movie was such a big hit it was
mastering Commander yeah dude that was
like the day when you it was still like
big male action stuff I didn't know that
stuff yeah Peter weird directed that
[__] dude movie God he's been in
everything huh he was really falling off
around Body of Lies and then that state
of uh what is that one that oh my God
I think proof of life was a big hit that
was after Cinderella Man was just like
that's when he started going down really
it wasn't big no how do you know 310 of
Yuma was big because it was a bomb
virtualacity my favorite he's amazing in
that my favorite my favorite Russell
Crow film I do love virtuosity I really
do all right well anyway enough talking
about Russell Crowe no this is the
Russell Crowe podcast the Russell
crowcast yeah uh crowcast If he if he
had a podcast called crowcast dude I bet
he does he only had camera Crow on it um
and then in a real Crow and The Black
Crows yeah what do you think Rob oh
um all right so let's go into some stuff
yeah but yeah well we'll do we'll do
we'll talk about stuff for Lifeline
luxury a good Lifeline larger uh but
patreon.com life and I agree all right
it's good I've seen a video in a while
ago about gambling addiction oh yeah I
was shirtless and as you can see I got
that shirt back there we go all right no
but uh I made that video long before I
submitted it I had some friends that are
fans of yours that were like submitted
it'll be on the show and I was like all
right I've submitted before it probably
won't be yeah here you are sure everyone
submitted a lot of videos and then it
was on Father's Day and I was like [__]
I need to rectify this
so
between the time I actually recorded
that video and now this is Spence months
I have started a company with my friend
and I make a quarter million dollars a
year roughly wow and I haven't gambled
and gambling wasn't
really about money more than it was
about maybe
I was drinking so I'm going to poker
online and I would drink and get home
and get on my phone and like yeah put
200 bucks on time yeah sometimes win
like five grand or lose it or whatever
keep going keep going you know how it is
I do but um to run this company and be
successful as we are I had to put
drinking on the back burner with that
the urge and the need to play poker
online or to to gamble has is is
diminished completely I have no urge I
don't care
um
I've been addicted to multiple things
historically with different drugs and
stuff and I knew that alcohol was a
substitution in the gambling on top of
that was another one and removing the
drinking and just being hard-pressed
about removing it took away that like
potential loss of money with gambling
and stuff like that so I'm good just so
you know but to answer questions Chris
yes I did try to stop when I was
drinking and I couldn't stop gambling or
drinking so it took the measures of the
initial thing to stop and know Matt I
didn't bet 50 or 60 000 like you thought
in the last video I said that I had made
forty to sixty thousand dollars
uh profit and two years playing poker I
probably bet 10 grand over the course of
two years and made 60 Grand so it was
like
good but sometimes the swings would be
like 800 or a thousand or two thousand I
wouldn't have money for what I needed so
yes Chris I have lost money that I've
needed right but that's all done now and
I'm in a place where my family's fed
everything's good I have no need I have
extra money no need to ask for more
money on gambling and no need to drink
yeah so I think I'm in a place now where
maybe I'm fortunate or maybe I just have
a good head on my shoulders to walk away
from it but this one as you know cool
your advice was spot on and I'm good
thanks buddy thank you guys you know
what yeah just uh
you know uh stay awake and don't get too
comfortable but I will say though we
were just talking about this man like so
weird that uh addiction it just
permeates into other stuff if you don't
keep yourself in check you know like if
you have that is very true yeah if you
have a gambling addiction and then you
get get you you you just stop gambling
and you don't like do the recovery work
it could you know morph into a drinking
or uh or or sex or online or porn or
whatever it is
um blasting hookers in an Alleyway
whatever the the thing is you know what
I mean yeah
um but yeah that that is uh really
um
you got to get to the root of it which I
you know I I always think you know it's
just about what happened to you and when
you were younger and what you got you
didn't get what you needed and and
you're using these things to cope and
some are not so healthy and gambling is
not so healthy and drinking is not so
healthy
um but yeah I I uh that's good dude you
got your shirt back and that's great and
it sounds like this guy's super
successful it sounds like yeah when I
was in rehab man everybody also had
addictions with other [__] too it was
like and I mean I'm talking about like
you know there were people in there for
what they thought was a sex addiction
that they which which was but then they
realized that it was and you know this
guy's one guy's addicted to uh violence
like there was a guy was addicted to
violence and there was a guy who's
addicted to like you know these
intrusive thoughts of you know
I was in rehab and one time the guy a
guy said to me uh
um you ever get like thoughts about like
killing people and I was like no no no
no you know and he was like yeah he's
like I've always had a fantasy of just
like holding somebody's head under water
in a sink and like just and like just
killing them that way and I was like huh
oh my God I was like huh that's
interesting thing to bring up somebody
you don't know extremely
I just I just [__] too much but yeah
that's I mean he he
um oh I knew him really well because it
was I was there for a while yeah yeah
yeah yeah but um and I was like what is
it about that and he was like just the
intimacy of like them almost being able
to get out but they can't and I was like
that's that's what makes me upset about
it yeah no [__] not also if I told you
what he did for a living you'd be
shocked I'll tell you off air okay but
it's unbelievable you're like oh
you're out there you guys are out there
yeah maybe I don't want to know yeah
well I'll let it I'll let it I'm gonna
tell you no matter what yeah but
um so anyway so that kind of stuff is
like addiction is it's very uh pervasive
right so there you go it's like uh
spilled water it'll always find the
crack you know make sure you don't spill
the water Bruce Lee the addiction is
like spoon
made him English at the end they just
get something
all right all right next one
hey Matt and Chris love your show I
listen every single week
um discuss it with my sisters every
single week okay guys
um you guys have the same
exact humor as me and my sisters do and
we're all around the same age so like
you reference a lot of the inside jokes
that we had growing up and movies and
stuff so it's really cool to listen to
you guys every week and share that with
each other
um I am submitting this video about
episode 62 love and life Matt uh you
sang this song Love and life and you
mentioned that you can't remember
where you heard your song from
um I believe I know which song you're
talking about it's from a movie from the
90s called house guest with Phil Hartman
and wow um this is it
a song oh my gosh dude and let me know
dude that's it oh my goodness
oh my God is that really what it is yes
dude
loving life house guests with Phil
Hartman and uh simbad yep
I mean I've watched the movie so it must
be that I know that movie is [__]
hilarious right yeah dude that movie is
very funny all right let's see when
Sinbad's in the dentist has to has
nothing oh my God has to act like he's a
dentist yeah oh that part's so funny
yeah but we can't play this on here
we're gonna get demonetized right here
we go
the Pro Shop will fix yeah
well the two of the funniest people dude
I know truly
ever look at Hartman
[Music]
dude that's crazy that you've been
seeing that so much forever and that's
what it's from
loving life okay whoever I don't think
she said her name write to me on
Instagram and I want to thank you that
is amazing dude you did it thank you how
the F like how she even said it growing
up with the same thing same inside joke
yeah yeah yeah one of her sisters was
like what's that one thing those goes
like love and life and her sister was
like oh it's from housekeeper how did
she giving her sister the credit but how
did she she's a genius but how did how
do you remember that that's so weird
that that but we remember weird stuff
though I know I know I know but this it
just reaches it just goes to show you
how massive this podcast is the number
one practice in the world yeah it is
um wow that's crazy I really did do it
that was it literally been trying to
figure that out yeah for a long time way
over a decade oh dude you've been always
sending voicemail to love and laugh dude
and you and Chris everybody always
thought it wasn't a real song yeah I
just thought you were making a like an
idiot no I mean I wow that's so bad
there's a song called love and life you
know it's my favorite song now I know
where to how to listen to it now you can
let's do it in the car and stuff yeah
dude
set my alarm in the morning to it
wow so 90s that whole thing wow the
whole thing when they're doing that yep
oh wow
everybody that in like there's the most
Chevy Chase thing in the world you know
oh wow
you know what Fletch sucked okay flash
did suck and also so did everything
Chevy Chase ever did it really Saft the
vacation thing like oh that's his thing
but dude he's not a real guy really yeah
I like him in that Paul Simon video but
that's nothing there's nothing that's
just him goofing off but something is
nothing yeah all right cool speaking for
Harmony and Caddyshack what what the
[__] did you say to me
isn't Chevy Chase I actually don't know
I know probably makes sense but it's
Robert Rodney Dangerfield Robert
Dangerfield Rodney Dangerfield
um Bill Murray uh
I bet Chevy's also in it Jim Belushi's
in it right yeah I don't know John sorry
Perry Mason and Jim Belushi all right
cool uh next one it's Australian what's
up you guys this is Patrick from San
Diego
um before I get started I just want to
say thank you for doing the podcast you
two are some of the funniest people I
know oh yeah um and I even used to
listen to Loveline a lot when I was
younger so YouTube to come together and
kind of recreate that has been amazing
uh my question today is about my
girlfriend she is the absolute love of
my life but sometimes she can get a
little carried away with her obsessive
Tendencies and uh superstitions to be
particular she gets in the car the other
day and tells me that she's been
researching superstitions oh no and that
she would like to start following the
one that says that you're not supposed
to whistle indoors because you don't
know what type of entities you may be
summoning I mean with your whistling
that's not yeah that's not something I
mean I am a very musical person I
Whistle all the time right so I felt a
little you know taken back by this
statement yeah
um deal breaker please let me know any
advice you guys have for that particular
thing as well as any advice you have for
living with somebody who has those kind
of obsessive Tendencies and may you know
lean into them uh more than you do
um let me know look here's the here's
the here's here's the deal yeah if you
are prone to being superstitious don't
no go into the world and look for more
100 they always get in the way don't so
they're not Google it they're not
genuine they're not genuine like you
don't go get someone else's
superstitions you have your own ones
that you wish you didn't have yeah but
you have them and you hate them and
that's that's how it is though you gotta
have a strict rule sweetie don't go
looking for more problems you're not
gonna google [__] you're not gonna
google superstitions and be like oh
there are no more they're gonna have a
bunch of them after that yeah and
whistling endorse is fine dude
oh no I know but it's just it's just so
silly and that's a big problem and she
needs to I call it the nipping in the
bud what you want to do is you got to
just if you really wanted to make it
stop you wanna
take out her eyes you want to say it's
exactly like fill in the blank about a
thing that she hates and I'm sure you
can find it whether that's like religion
or any kind of like group think or
kind of illogical thing that she doesn't
isn't into all you want to do is compare
to that and say they're the exact same
thing yeah and that could work because
also you're not lying it's not like a
strategy to like guess no yeah that's
just true you know what I mean so don't
welcome try to make it try to make her
understand
that it is completely empty of meaning
entirely that's not gonna help uh and
and that's why I mean look you're not
going to change her mind but you have to
at least change her mind about what you
do yeah also expose your therapy so just
whistle more in the house you know it's
it's not going to do that only in houses
where there's demons that will be bad
though you don't want to just whistle
you want to make sure that you have the
kind of whistle that brings out summons
things yeah yeah you got to be you gotta
you gotta really nip this in the butt if
you don't you can't be love and laughing
yeah
we can't even call it actually we could
call 11 life part two this episode no
but we can't we could but we're not we
could franchise love in life and we
could make it a universe yeah below and
then make the love and Life podcast yeah
we would actually be so big it would be
like Marvel hmm you're like DC
um so yeah I don't know I mean uh that's
horrible but she's got to get help for
that because that sucks and that's a
mental that's a it's OCD really is what
it is that's a very I just I've got to
be honest I've never known anyone who's
like I'm a superstitious person let me
go out into the world and like I'm like
a vessel for Superstition let me just
like find other superstitions and then
I'll like live my life according to them
that is gonna eventually just never
leave her right that's a recipe for
being an active recipe for disaster he's
a agoraphobe what is the agoraphobia
um so they're afraid of Agora Hills
stupid
don't ever [__] say that to me again
um
so he so yeah I I that's
being obsessive about that [__] is I
don't
it is so weird that she would want to go
out and find more because the truth is
I hate that stuff so much exactly that I
don't want to know more stuff yeah right
I'll turn off a TV show if it's gonna be
like triggering for me and my OCD or
something like that she's playing with
fire ask her why she's playing with fire
why would she be like a fire honey why
are you playing with fire sweetie listen
I don't understand why there's a bunch
of fire around here playing with it
let's discuss and then get into it and
then you could be love and live loving
life now that's a real song I can sing
it see yeah I knew it all along I feel
so Vindicated that's my wife
that's my wife the woman
who said what the song was we're married
oh okay not now we're married yeah
already now after she's like basically
went through a ceremony I haven't asked
her yet I don't know her name but it's
official I don't know where she is I
don't know anything about her but we're
married okay
cool so I wonder where she is yeah me
too actually I love you guys love the
podcast uh Chris I will see you in
Hamilton in September yeah super excited
um so I'm looking for you guys advice on
how to tell my parents it's time to put
down a family dog
um he is 19 years old I love him to
death I have him tattooed on my arm like
he's I'm 28 so he's been around for my
entire life pretty much wow um but he is
blind he's deaf he has dementia
um he doesn't have any teeth he attacks
everybody because he doesn't know where
he is or who we are
um he barely eats so he's like Skin and
Bones
um
and yeah the quality of life is just
like not that great anymore but my
parents are in complete denial
um I no longer live at home and I have
my own dog so I've been trying to kind
of like tell them what I'm seeing from
the outside but they're just like
complete denial yeah and I don't want to
be the person that's like pushing to
kill the family dog but I also know that
like
it might be the responsible thing to do
to put them down and his quality of life
isn't that great right now so
yeah I'm just looking for advice on how
to kind of make them see that
um yeah I'd appreciate it okay so let me
ask you a question why is it responsible
to kill a dog
what why is it responsible to kill the
dog well that's gonna be baked into my
advice so let me just do it all of this
okay so you clearly love this dog and
everyone knows that especially your
parents you literally have the dog
tattooed on your arm you grew up with a
dog the dog's basically a [__] family
member to you specifically at this point
not that it's a competition but you
could make a case that you are the most
attached to the star
remind your parents how deep your love
is for this dog how much you want it to
live forever even though that's
unrealistic all of that and say as that
person who loves this our dog so much
I see it in pain and it's never going to
get better in fact it's only going to
continue to get worse which it has been
doing for a long time now and as the as
someone who loves the dog I have to
put forth the idea that I think it's the
better thing to do
to put the dog out of its business more
Humane it's more Humane and in fact what
you're doing now you know this is where
you got to be really careful but in
plain English to you not you to them
they're being extremely selfish they're
not actually caring for the dog yeah
there's a thresh there's a there's a
Tipping Point where at some point it's
like you're you're keeping the dog alive
just for you yeah and the dog would
rather be out of its misery that is
where you're at now for sure what you
just described is well beyond any dog
that I've ever put down and I've had to
put dogs down that I love very much
because they're
their life sucks dude it's like they're
it's like they're in hell and and ending
their life would take them out of hell
and into vast nothingness that is like
way better than hell what about if I'm
well okay so let me be Devil's Advocate
alive isn't better than everything let
me just that's that's the point vote for
me alive isn't better than everything
vote for me governor of California
um I think that
um okay let me play Devil's Advocate
okay yeah well if the dog didn't like
his life so much why doesn't it commit
suicide
only because it doesn't have thumbs what
could jump off a building not if it
can't get into a building it could
poison itself not if it can't obtain
poison
see what I'm saying you need to hang it
up no needs thumbs yeah it could buy a
gun no needs car needs a car to get it
yeah that's not why but yeah yeah no I
dude a dog can't shoot itself because he
needs to drive right to the gun store uh
yeah okay so all right you're you're
completely right too what about that
guide your uh
approach like you are absolutely correct
that dog hates living right now
it's only alive because your parents
make it beautiful why doesn't it walk
into oncoming traffic
maybe they live in a rural area or it's
blind and it can't doesn't know where it
is you're hearing is yeah exactly there
you go maybe it's hearing's gone how
about you next time you go over run the
dog over and pretend it's by myself it's
like The Sopranos I don't know what
happened I don't know nothing yeah or
do it and say there it's done it never
needs to happen again I don't want to
talk about it and then play Love and
laugh loving life yeah dude you're in
the right it is a righteous decision to
do that it's it's not a good one not an
easy one so yeah they'll respect you if
you really come out look
I don't know
then again if you just think animals are
there to make adult make human lives
better oh there you go then I guess they
should just hold on to it until it
expires on its own get it taxidermied
but if you're asking I mean she's not
asking this she knows what the most
Humane thing is she's about the approach
you want to approach it like from a
place of making sure that you are
repeating repeatedly reminding them that
they don't love the dog more than you do
also you're coming from a place of Love
yeah yeah also you can offer it you can
offer to go do it you know so they don't
have to do it dude when I was I don't
know if it's about the act of okay yeah
I get it but yeah that's a good idea I
can do 10 pull-ups now I'm so sorry what
I can do 10 pull-ups now
that when I started back working out I
could only do four okay okay so that's
[__] a huge Improvement very quickly
absolutely heartless though you know
what I mean we're talking about
someone's family dog dying and that's
tragic I'm just trying to add some
levity dude but yeah I do feel for you
that's rough yeah that's that's ruff
ruff no no that's heartless okay now
that was the most heartless thing that
ever happened on this podcast by the way
okay next
good luck what up Matt what up Chris
coming to you live from the Home Depot
I'm just on lunch break right now I just
came across a video that I was in
episode 21. so much coke I was asking um
budgeting questions on how um I should
budget once I transfer to Texas Tech I'm
so much code and um Matt gave me the
advice of getting a job uh one thing I
didn't mention was I had a job at the
time which is the same one I do here at
Home Depot
um but I'm just so bad at giving detail
but uh okay so yeah
just checking in on that I'm good but I
have another question for y'all so this
girl that I've known basically my whole
life goes to Texas Tech um and is in our
friend group okay she had just recently
told me her feelings that she has for me
and uh like she wants to like I guess
start a relationship or something and I
told her
um that I wasn't ready for a
relationship and I guess I just want
more advice on how to go about this
whole situation because
obviously you all know better so thank
you well here I he obviously hit it
already
no I don't think so I think he hit it
you don't think he would have said that
he's he leaves details out
I mean fair enough but if he's not
saying that part he's a [__] because
that is essential that is a sentence he
hit it already otherwise he wouldn't be
saying he'd be like should I I don't
know you know but or he just does not
attracted to her at all I thought that
that's what I thought okay like he's
just not really like right that's not
really it's also College bro but I I if
you want the thing to say like the best
thing to say because and I'm assuming at
least a little bit of it is true and if
a little bit of it is true when it comes
to either hurting or not hurting
someone's feelings it's okay to say
something that is like a little bit true
but uh I think you wanna not you want to
say that you don't want to mess with the
Friendship yeah let's test out on
someone your whole life and now she
wants to start a relationship it's a
completely valid reason to be like well
I don't
it's also dead wrong to just be like I
know I don't know if I'm ready for a
relationship that's that's stupid yeah
just if you don't just be like I don't
want to mess up the Friendship dude yeah
if you think you might just say sweetie
Let's test out it let's test out the
[__] let's give it a test ride Let's
test out the horizontal Mambo let's see
if we like it you know I'll push inside
you we'll thrust in and out for a while
I'll go splurt Whoopsie Daisy we'll wear
a rubber and then we'll see what happens
she's just like never mind never mind
you know what I mean I thought you were
different you know what look I'll get on
top a little bit you'll get on top a
little bit we'll do a little [__]
lazy Republican and we'll hang out we'll
have a good time Luke is the lazy
Republican the least Republicans were
your boss lay on your side and she's
they're both facing the same way and you
just kind of you're just having sex and
making passive income that's the lazy
Republican
you know like this yeah you know
same-sex marriages are wrong right
um
yeah yeah I don't know
you don't believe in abortion do you hey
[__] Bud Light right this so
oh yeah [__] bottom line yeah the worst
Dirty Talk Dylan Mulvaney is a man the
worst dirty talk ever you know that you
know that's what it says [__] uh [__]
dude
um
yeah so I just uh yeah so I
just either test out the horizontal
Mambo or tell her you don't want to ruin
the Friendship those are the only two
things if you're gonna test out the
horizontal Mambo they'll say let's just
test out let's give it a try
I'm just say oh make the whole thing
your whole point be about but I don't
want to mess up the friendship even if
you do want to like try it out or even
if you don't at all that is the thing to
stick to because I'm assuming again that
there is at least partially true dude
sweetie I'll come here come on sit down
there though let's test it out there we
go oh my God there we go that's nice and
like sweetie dog here we go and turn
around and oh there we go and up oh man
there we go yeah that's not gonna work
out
oh
[Laughter]
I just did the biggest dip [__] move of
all time just so bad
[Music]
foreign
wow I mean yeah on second thought just
say the friend thing don't test it out
you know yeah this is not gonna go well
and I'm it's been brought to my
attention that that is even if that's
not how it goes it'll be close enough to
what he just did that you wanted yeah
you want to avoid that you know yeah
um yeah okay that's not a good look
um even if that it takes four days for
you to realize after the splurt it's
still basically what I do right exactly
that's just sped up yeah yeah so don't
do that and four days after the splurt
say that that's what we should call the
episode
will that get flagged Florida for now
right four days after the splurk I mean
splurt you think splurt has a
necessarily sexual connotation could be
a water park is just like Anthony uh I
don't think it'll get flagged you don't
four days no no I agree there's no way
okay here we go for it okay relax but
everyone knows relax like it's amazing
you know I mean like it's amazing like
you're so excited about four days after
this I wish my new special footage after
this blurt and I will tell you this
though for the I wish you named your son
that your second one son four days after
the splurt Dalia hi Calvin and four days
after this so stupid dude
um all right cool what a good one yeah
what's up
I'm just calling in today looking for
some advice
um so I'm not technically from here
um I was born in Bosnia oh [__] but I
came here when I was three months old
okay my family is from there oh yeah
dude um so I've lived here for 25 plus
years
um I love my culture and and all that
that's cool I speak it fluently just as
well as my English pretty much
um but the thing that keeps happening to
me
um that's kind of annoying is whenever I
get introduced to new people
um the person Introducing Me will always
be like they start off with oh meet my
friend blah blah blah he's from Bosnia
right
and the people will always be like no
[__] way like and they'll try to ask
me questions about it and just kind of
make it super [__] awkward and weird
um so I guess my question or the advice
I'm looking for is how do I deal with
this [__]
um do I just kind of just stop being an
[__] and just deal with it and just
move on from there
um or do I be super dick about it going
forward have fun and just put on this
like super
shitty heavy at some and you can do that
act like I'm fresh off the boat or
something like
yeah you know when I was seven years old
I I break neck or Friday using my bare
legs or well that would be good yeah
yeah you know I I still drink I drink
milk from dog it's good for you you know
I don't know
I get it but yeah
um let me know what you guys think uh
what I should do going forward let me
know love the show love you guys take it
easy peace thanks he has no accent but
he does have that one he does have that
one thing that uh that bosnians and
sessions have
the L words
yeah which is very cool sounding I I
mean dude here's the deal man just don't
say you're Bosnian you were there for
three months well no here here's what
you do it's very simple foreign
you're American hey here's my friend
so-and-so he's Bosnian and that guy's
and Anthony just dropped something
pissed me off very much but it's all
good uh so you know here's my friend
so-and-so he's Bosnian you step forward
and all you have to say is
I'm not Bosnian yeah three months in
Bosnia dude yeah yeah also or turn to
your friend and say why do you always do
that also it's not here's me if someone
says hey uh here's my friend I don't
know his name Alex he's Bosnian here's
me oh cool hey what's up Alex
I I say
how what was it like during the war give
me a full account every single day I
want to know your exact experience and
the experience of your loved ones man
tell me in Bosnian right now and start
now that's what I do anytime I meet
someone from Bosnia so it sucks that
your friend does that sets you up like
that because then I would be really
disappointed
do it with an accent harder accent
harder accent
um but yeah here's the thing I actually
get it Bosnia in a language I get it
being a problem I don't know I'm sure
there's a specific dialect
you know drowning Arnold Schwarzenegger
um
but like I actually completely forgot
what I was gonna say which is done here
good and I'm pissed
um yeah just just I oh I get why you see
it as a problem but trust me this is
actually a non-problem because all you
got to do is say no I'm not if your
friend says that or say no I'm not and
then when you're alone with your friend
later say hey why do you honestly why do
you do that when you know it's not true
how about this dude I've been to Boston
because that's a fair question whoops
foreign
I've been to Bosnia for three months
more than you so stop saying that unless
he's been back to your friend yeah yeah
yeah yeah or anyone really because
nobody's been about so why does your
friend even say that so but he's saying
multiple people do it yeah why are they
doing that what the [__] dude stop
telling people you're Bosnian yeah maybe
don't start maybe I don't even let
anybody know that's what he does hey
what's up dude I'm Alex by the way I'm
Bosnian so anytime you ever meet anybody
tell them I'm Bosnian no and then he
calls in and does that
no he said anytime you enter hey I'm
Alex I'm Bosley and anytime you
introduce me to someone uh don't ever
introduce me as Bosnian which is what I
just did to you and then these people
are breaking that rule and so we called
in [__] [__] magic mine dude I feel
good because I took it uh cocaine okay
let's go all right
nickel sketch
and his friend was on the phone with him
and he was distracted yeah
um and I know uh you know Chris you were
saying that you really like that guy uh
but then he said maybe he's boring but
you really like that guy and uh Matt
suggested that maybe you marry him uh so
he's actually my little brother and I
just want to give my blessing and say I
think that would be nice he would be a a
beautiful couple so you know support it
great uh and that's it well thank you
what happened and what's happening uh
you gave his brother advice
uh and the advice was so like or the
your feelings about his brother were so
like glowing and positive that I made
the joke well if you like him so much
why don't you marry him oh okay and then
he just called in to give you his
Blessing and you're gonna throw that
again and it's gonna piss me off so I'm
marrying his brother or you are you
you're marrying his brother I already
have a wife
yeah well I don't think yeah that's the
problem okay well we can talk about it
later but I don't think that's gonna be
a problem
don't mean that you guys brother
who you don't even remember so your
brother called into the show or what so
you know what's one of the worst things
in the world when I think about it too
much is I think about arranged marriages
and it's so sad the fact that it still
happens is crazy let's see if I can do
anything
oh the fact that no one no one does that
well you just did I want to see if it
would hit the camera oh okay so now you
know no one does that either so hold on
so the fact that it's still a thing
where are arranged marriages there's a
lot of them in India and then okay what
you're gonna do is you're going to say
it after I say it in Middle East yeah uh
in Oklahoma but in other places in the
world too but they're common practices I
wish marriages were arranged in America
you do wish it yep only arranged you
couldn't choose why because then at
least we would understand why everybody
is so [__] up it'd be because of that
well people still understand that though
wow you're saying the reason is because
of marriages no no no no no no no
because of the arranged marriages no I
know you're you're saying it the range
marriage is worth thing we could blame
all of our [__] upness yep on the fact
their arranged marriages
I'm saying and as a politician I would
Lobby to remove a range of marriages and
then I could be a politician oh so you
wanna you want there to be a range
version so you can take them down and be
here yep okay so what were you gonna say
though no nothing you said you think
about arranged marriages all the time oh
yeah I think about all the time I just
think about how much that completely
sucks it does suck you know people like
selling their like literally like they
sell their daughter who has now become a
woman or needs to get married to become
a woman yeah a dowry
oh this is why I was thinking about
there's some crazy things going on this
is crazy thing going on in uh India
where women are getting married to
Indian men who are abroad at the time
there's like a term form okay and but
and they get all this money because like
they the parents think it's a good
marriage because he's he's like yeah out
of India he's making money yeah like
Switzerland or whatever so they give a
lot of Dowry no he is real but he keeps
the marriage takes all the Dowry and
stays
in Switzerland after they get married
and like lives a totally different life
and there's no recourse because they
have nothing to get to to to get him on
and it's like a huge like thousands and
thousands of women and families have
been scammed by these people yeah oh
nothing Dumber yeah it's crazy dude so
dumb dumb [__] leads to more scams stop
doing dumb [__] you get easier more
scams we don't want that I I imagine
having to marry somebody you don't want
to marry and then just every day after
work your [__] job a lot of people have
[__] jobs they gotta go back and hang
out with the person that they don't even
like who is terrible to them surely
because in a society where there's
arranged marriages I can't imagine that
like right neither person wants to be
there at least if you're the woman I
know it's like uh some of these places
are second class citizens but at least
if you're a woman you can then when
they're at work you're chilling I mean
if that's how it works if that's how it
works and then when they come home it
sucks it's like here comes [__] I
think it sucks always though why is it
better if they're gone because they can
watch The Bold and the Beautiful like
why is it better because they could
watch it okay because they can eat stuff
that they want they can chill they do
their day they go out and do errands I
bet I guarantee you actually that there
are
as in this country where arranged
marriage is still a thing it's just not
where I don't I'm probably Northwest up
in the Northwest like in like Forest
areas where all the Neo-Nazi skinheads
are yup okay
that's a good guess yep because you'd
think oh somewhere down south and this
and that nope dude where all the
neo-nazis are dude yeah it's weird that
there's so many new Nazis in Washington
what's up with that it's because it's
super liberal though too and that makes
no sense well there's super liberal
people right and Nazis yeah that's what
I'm saying you can't have one without
the other because you have that little
blue dot in the middle and then in the
outskirts it's all red
thanks man you should be on CNN with the
how they have the map the guy with the
map you know you see how their skin
heads and then on the outside of that
it's all red and that's where you get
the neo-nazis yeah because in the in the
in the in the in the blue dot in the
middle that's where you get everybody
interested in all everyone's rights and
then outside of that that's where the
neo-nazis come in anyway back to you guy
with the two big head because everyone
always has a two big head on that two
big head yep
to Live Crew are we gonna do another one
I'm still ready hey what's up chance uh
my name is Jonah from Reading
Pennsylvania yeah see you soon I last
saw you back in 2017 in Tallahassee and
uh I actually went and saw you
completely by myself so hell yeah I love
that at the time of my life man so uh
that's cool and uh Matt big fan of
mentally he's confused
um some of your acting work man so uh
seriously been a chew baby all along for
the Delia Brothers but um
uh my issue tonight is in regards to
um asking someone out so um I have this
girl I really like
um every time I'm with her seniorly hit
it off
um don't really see her too too often
really only like friends events and
parties and things like that
um
the only thing is is that she is the
sister of one of my really really good
friends
um so if I was going to approach that
and ask her out
um how would I do that uh I'm sort of
thinking
um something along the lines of like
should I ask her brother um should I
sort of tell them it's gonna happen
um you know how do I should I approach
him first I approach her first you know
that sort of thing uh trying to sort of
figure that out um he's not too too
protective of her or anything like that
but he's someone that would want to be
in the know if something like that was
going on so
um yeah that's really all I got uh
hopefully I can follow up with you guys
eventually depending on what you say and
um hope to hear back appreciate it
thanks thanks dude what a nice guy
reading I'll be in Reading uh
Pennsylvania yep I'll see you there in
Reading Pennsylvania if you think he's
the kind of guy that would want to be in
the know and you're good friends with
him obviously say something just be like
yo I was thinking I'm gonna ask you out
your sister yeah exactly it doesn't he
mentioned something that I I think is
something that men don't think about
ahead of time until this kind of thing
happens to them but he said like should
I ask him or should I tell him and it's
like it doesn't have to be that black
and white yeah I know it's a conundrum
but you can you can tell but but also
show the person your respect you don't
have to be like hey dude I'm dating your
sister Ace yo I'm gonna [__] date
your sister right and then he starts
or you do both you could ask and also
tell you could say I'm gonna date your
sister
right that's technically still a
statement though because you didn't use
the words but you did I'm gonna date
your sister yeah
um but yeah you should just be like hey
I'm really into your sister uh I'm I
really want to ask her out and I just
you know I because you're such a good
friend I didn't want you to like hear
about it somewhere else and like I just
want to make sure I told you that isn't
giving him the opportunity to say you
can't do that not that he would do that
or can do that but like I think that's
what's in a guy's head when they say
should I tell him or should I ask him
like it's like you don't need to pick
one you don't ask because you live in a
free country it's a free Society you can
do whatever you want and you know you
don't have to tell because there's like
a sense of
confrontation there or something just
like say it in a nice way but do say
something because it's not because he
like reserves the right to know what his
sister's up to that has nothing to do
with it he doesn't but it's like there
is a certain thing if you're he said
he's really good friends with this guy
yeah that would be kind of just weird if
a good friend of yours
yeah like asked your sister out and you
had no idea yeah it's just like weird
you're asking for like some weird kind
of thing to happen yeah so to avoid
weirdness I think it's it's the best
thing to do
um
did he specify if his really good friend
is a guy or a girl no but I think it's a
guy I do too but
um if it's a girl that doesn't change
things does it
uh I don't I don't think it changes that
you should say something no it's the
same the same answer for sure yeah but I
think maybe he wouldn't have called in
for advice if uh because he's sexy and
because I was just gonna say and the
reason for that is because the guy who
called in who you said is oh he's so
nice he's actually a sexist he's got a
lot of problems yeah he's a male
chauvinist he's a sexist and
um so he's being very respectful I think
that's good uh and yeah you should say
it to him
but yeah oh okay well there's no reason
to be that much louder I mean coming no
oh that didn't it okay
um
yeah Matt's right
and I'm right too and I would have said
that even if
uh uh all right man what's up you just
stretched you just give it I stretched
and I got really really really [__]
good a good stretch and I yawned hard so
you feel like you're gonna I'm like
loose dude but I've been pretty loose
this episode to be brutally honest with
you yeah you seem to be honest you
seemed a little down at the beginning of
the episode really a little bit no way
you're saying that because I didn't talk
about my deadlifts and stuff oh that's
not why but it is I I made a conscious
effort to I'm like a dude I'm knocking
because you're like you're throwing a
wet towel on yourself yeah dude so
whatever
[Laughter]
you asked for it you asked for it you're
gonna so this is what you get now
they're gonna be a bad mood because I
don't have to talk about my body okay
cool that's all good all right well I
apologize feel free to talk about uh no
I'm just gonna get more tattoos and I'm
gonna keep working out it's gonna be
fantastic and I look good I'm 43 but I
look good dude you're 43 damn you're
only for only for a while
you're old dude well you're what I don't
even know I'm literally oh yeah you're
gonna be 40. literally 13.
what it's crazy I'm 13 years old gray in
your beard nuts you know it's like the
movie Jack
that's so [__] stupid to not say
Benjamin buttons you know dude Jack is
the better example Jack honestly
Benjamin Button Benjamin jack off no
here's the thing Benjamin Button ages
backwards I know but that's the Jack
ages well rapidly I know I know I was
saying it I don't know that's really
different though and I don't like people
being like oh they're similar like it's
not similar but also Benjamin buttons
was a book it's also a love story short
story it wasn't a book it was a short
story and it was a love story and I read
it I read it backwards so it made sense
wow a Vaudeville comedian a bunch of
buns every backwards it makes sense from
the direct from hey the writer from the
director of Mento Memento I wasn't even
who directed it that's the David Fincher
movie not a Christopher Nolan so dork
boo yeah and oh let's see oh yeah Booyah
I know that I'm saying Benjamin Button
from the same directors as Memento
because they're both going backwards
even though that's not the same guy yeah
okay but you didn't know this is
somebody out there didn't know and I
said it for them
okay so it's all good
um hey you know who wrote me uh the
director do you care about this the
director of speak no evil Anthony
remember you told me not to watch that
movie because of how horrific it is yeah
you what what he wrote to you so I
talked about it on my podcast yeah
because it's one of my top 10 greatest
movies of all time yeah and he was like
dude thank you so much it made my day
somebody sent it to me he wrote me in
what's his name I forget but he wrote me
in
December and I didn't see until
yesterday
and uh and I wrote him back I was like
oh my God I just saw this your movie's
amazing
Christian Taft drop that's what it is I
say a few of his movies
on Instagram
his last name is just a bunch of letters
a bunch of made up words his last name
was just somebody got Scrabble and and
put them in no particular order and
that's his last name go is this a word I
say no have you seen that movie by the
way speak no evil yeah
uh no
no no
it's fantastic oh it's a Danish movie
yep they make the best movies
no man yeah they do no man every time I
see a Danish movie I'm like wow okay
well that's your opinion yeah I mean
wrong that's just your opinion yeah
uh okay all right all right so you got a
guy that wrote to you and said good job
congrats man that was me literally all
the time okay uh all right well that's
it for this episode if you want more uh
guess what get some lifelong luxury
I was gonna say he cut me off
patreon.com Lifeline luxury white line
I will be in Charlotte I will be in
Little Rock Arkansas I will be in Vegas
coming up soon I added another date and
uh a bunch of different places Montreal
Edmonton go to chrisley.com
Nashville if you want to if you also
want to go to matilia.com for one-on-one
sessions with me no one else just me
just the two of us or if you want
someone else on your side of the screen
just three of us or even more you get
three you get four four of us uh but
yeah if you have a question for the show
click the link in the description below
or just go to watch lifeline.com or
leave us a message at the hotline at
213-973-8095 and please oh please do not
forget to get the merch it is amazing
Chris meant to wear his today but he
forgot because he's
just like that uh go to
lifelinemerch.com for all that also
leave a comment dude I said that dude
leave a comment agree with me tell Chris
he's wrong thank you
[Music]
hello